if there is something totally consuming
about the way nature builds life out of
death the Amazon is a wonderful example
of this because the Amazon is the most
living place you have ever seen and at
any given moment all organic material is
bound in living systems 95% bound in
living systems you don't find forest
floor detritus and rotting logs and
stuff like that in the Amazon if the
leaf falls within minutes or hours at
most it has been found by leaf cutter
ants or some other pathogen that begins
to return it to the cycle of life this
kind of economy this kind of stability
through utilization of flow is the
design principle that we have ignored
for several thousand years and that
offers a way out
dynamic equilibrium an abandonment of
the possibility of closure closure is a
neurotic and infantile demand to make
upon reality other people language you
just have to live in this state of
dynamic disequilibrium which if
sustained long enough and insufficient
taste becomes a life well-lived
the shaman knows this because they
plunge into this realm where everything
is transient flow and interlocking field
where the materiality of the ordinary
reality is overcome by the quantum
mechanical wave mechanical maternal face
behind appearances and again you know it
must be Moby Dick morning a have says if
you would strike strike through the mass
it is behind the mask reality is a mask
because reality enforces this idea of
permanence
but not if carefully examined women know
this because women see birth bury the
dead raise the children they exist in
the still main of flow but the male
dominant ego because it is transient and
has great anxiety about that refuses
this primary intuition and when I say
that the original partnership society
was stabilized through boundary
dissolution that's what I mean the
dissolution of the assumption of
permanence me my existence my women my
food my children my weapons my land my
this mother you know all of that is seen
as a fiction that's why primitive people
are so amused by us and our concerns and
our clutching because they know easy
come easy go and if we could learn this
one thing this is what the plants are
trying to teach I think that the border
between life and death
between being and not being between me
being me and me being you is so trivial
and so arbitrary that it can only be
seen as the the outer iridescent on the
real reality within this is the secret
of of a happy life I think I mean I
certainly don't claim to achieve it I am
fraught with the eigen bite of in with
the torments of the 42 year old Irish
male California heavily mortgaged soul
but but this but I saw it I saw it I saw
what it was and what it is is it's a
coming to terms with impermanence and
that gives you authentically that
nothing can take away and courage and
presence in the moment and humor and
survivability survivability and if you
hold instead to be in violent pearl of
that which cannot be destroyed
everything becomes your enemy time
becomes your enemy space becomes your
enemy and you are doomed to that a have
faith because hey it's bigger than any
of us you can't push the river
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]